as a YouTube creator one of the most
frustrating and challenging things is
getting new subscribers you know you
feel like you put a lot of love into
your videos you you're you're not trying
to be people off you know you're really
trying to add value and you're doing all
of the best practices right you've got
the little call-to-action button at the
end saying subscribe you've got the
little thumbnail on the top right of
every video to subscribe you're putting
a subscription link in the description
below and yet you're not getting enough
people subscribing it's frustrating what
I did was I discovered a simple trick
using the 51 rule that helped me get a
thousand new subscribers in one month
and I want to share it so that you guys
can do something similar as a little bit
of context I went from 2400 subscribers
at a month to 3400 subscribers in a
month using this technique so what's the
fifty one rule you may be familiar with
the 80/20 rule which means 80% of your
revenue for example comes from 20% of
the customers or 80% of your views may
come from 20% of the videos I found that
when applying it to subscribers on a
youtube channel it's more like fifty to
one where 50% of your subscribers will
come from 1% of your videos I applied
this to my channel and found that 51% of
my new subscribers came from 1% of my
videos now I have 1,700 videos on my
channel which means 17 out of the 1,700
videos I have are leading to 50% of my
new subscribers to my channel so what I
did was find that 1% of videos that's
really making a difference and making it
obvious on those videos that I want
people to subscribe to the channel what
I do is at the top of those videos have
a very big very clear call to action
want more subscribe to the channel and
make that as an annotation now that
would be annoying to have in all your
videos especially for your repeat
subscribers right for the people who are
coming back and watching all your videos
over and over and over again they don't
want to see that but for a first time
person visiting your channel that's the
first video that they see it's not as
annoying it's it's a value wise
to risk them because it gives them the
opportunity to join your channel so now
how do you find that 1% of videos that's
making a difference YouTube actually
makes it super simple and easy to do
through their analytics so the first
thing you want to do is load up your
Creator studio back-end and go to
analytics next you want to scroll down
to where it says subscribers this will
show you where you're getting
subscribers from how many you've gained
how many you've lost and what the source
is the real value that was clicking then
on the video link under the source this
page will then show you which video led
to new subscribers and you'll always see
that some videos do way better than
others helping justify the 51 rule so
then you can go into each of those top
1% videos and add a big annotation again
it's a helpful reminder for new
subscribers and it's not going to upset
your current subscribers because
probably they've already seen that video
and it's not on the 99% of the other
videos on your channel so that's how I
use a 51 rule to gain a thousand new
subscribers to my channel hopefully you
can use it to apply it to your channel
as well good luck continue to believe
and if you have tips strategies ideas
suggestions questions on how to get more
subscribers to your youtube channel I'd
love to hear from you in the comments
below thank you so much for watching
I'll see you soon
every week I share inspiring and
motivational stories that really mean
something to me
that I hope you'll check out in my
newsletter below
you